foreign
is with us in Austin Texas hi Laura how
are you
I'm fine thank you for taking my call
today sure how can we help well I have
two adult daughters
um one my husband and I do 34 and 35 and
the 35 year old
is married and lives in Colorado
and a year ago uh October we were going
to go take a trip up to see her but due
to the pandemic and our very different
views on masking and social distancing
and all of that
it ended up we had a heated conversation
and she has
cut us out of her life completely
so we got a letter from her the
following day an email saying we're all
done we wouldn't have anything to do
with us he changed her number changed
her email
and all cards and correspondence have
been returned unopened so I waited a
whole year
and you know I have a will we have a
will we both have Wills
um basically it's a 50 50 for our girls
um but given where we're at now I'm like
I don't feel comfortable if I were to
die tomorrow to leave that daughter
money if she won't even contact me or
take my calls
and I don't know how to handle that
whether I should is it appropriate for
me to change my will or should I look at
it like I'm well I'm not going to be
here I won't know anything about that
just leave it and move on
I'm so sorry
uh it well I waited a year because it's
like a death no it's it's
worse than a death
because they're still there
yes
got married two weeks ago and she you
know struggled to the the her sister had
cut her out as well a few months before
us so soyman your other daughter just
got married and her sister didn't come
to the wedding
no I'm so sorry no and she wasn't she
didn't invite her because
um oh she knew that the invitation would
have come back
unopened so nothing we have not been
able unless we drove a thousand miles to
Colorado from Texas we would never she
just returns everything says refused
Return to Sender
to cover a mask in Social distancing
both of which both of which have turned
out to not be true after the smoke
cleared this is so sad
it is and you know we couldn't hug her
and I that was our thing we said well if
we can't hug our daughter when we come
there we don't see the value in US
coming we want to we want to see you and
hug you and you know it's been two years
let's let's get together and it just
wasn't gonna be yeah fear is fear is a
sad sad thing
it uh the terror that took over people's
mental uh ability to do uh
the number of these stories out there is
just staggering it's it's the um it's
one of the huge costs of
the mythology that was out there in the
name of Science and the cost of
people believing one thing and not
believing another is just so sad just so
sad it is it is your heart I mean as a
mom there's a mom your heart must be
just completely broken so it is uh what
I what you have to do
for you
not because it's an ethical thing or a
moral thing it's a part of your grieving
process is you have to change your will
okay I'm comfortable with no no it's not
it's like it's like that's not about me
it's that's you admitting
what has happened
right in the in the Jewish culture
you'll hear them say you are dead to me
you are dead to me
yes and it goes back to the story
um that was that happened in Jewish
culture the Christians call the story of
The Prodigal Son and you are dead to me
and so dead means that the person is
still alive but there's no longer any
Financial or relational interaction
anymore and in the Jewish culture if you
don't have a financial interaction and
you don't have a relational interaction
it is worse than a death and so that's
it comes from the you know the the
mindset of the prodigal son and that's
what the prodigal son did he came in and
took the inheritance before his father
died and went and squandered it right
you know the story I do and so but that
there's a reason for all of that in that
culture and
um that is it's a mental health reason
and it's it's for you to process the
loss of your daughter
yes I'm so sorry
yeah though just the changing of the
changing of the will is just a part of
you grieving and recovering from this if
it changes you can always come back if
the situation changes you can always
come back and change it later and you're
not doing this to punish her
because she's not even going to know it
you know and uh I think that that that's
the thing you think about is well when
I'm gone and she would find out that
that's the cost of doing business the
way she's done business
okay and it's uh but that's not that's
not relevant that this is not about
punishment and it's not about revenge
and it's not about vengeance it's not
about hitting back for the hurt this is
about closing the loop closing the
closing the storyline line and uh if we
can open the storyline later
that is fine
um but but it would not be it's not good
mental health for you to leave the will
dangling as a false hope in your mind
and that's what's that's what it's doing
I just I I to throw this in there I
would just offer a bit of a challenge
even if the will is changed
um I think it'd be easy at that point to
just go this story is done and she's cut
out of my life and I want nothing to do
with her and then sit with anger and
unforgiveness I think that especially if
the will is changed in order to get to
the story of The Prodigal Son and be
like that father you have to have a
heart of forgiveness so that if the
daughter ever comes back you receive her
with open arms so I would just encourage
you to also still work through those
emotions and the hurt and the anger that
comes from whatever argument there was
and work on forgiving that daughter so
that if the story continues at some
point you're ready for it and and you
can have a relationship again
yeah and again that's what I'm saying
your motivation is not about hitting
back your motivation is not anger based
it's just sadness it's going this is the
recognition that she's not in our life
and so it is it's illogical and it's bad
psychology and bad spiritual to leave
her in there at this point
um but it's not it hasn't really
anything to do with her it's got to do
with you
and that's kind of what forgive that's
what forgiveness is as well what
Christine's talking about I mean that's
got to do with you not her because she's
not receiving anything
you know because you're not talking to
her there's no way to get to her and you
can't and no I'm not going to show up on
her front porch and confront her
cutting I mean she made this decision
she's a grown-up you cannot control
other people's decisions and you didn't
cause it
um you just disagreed I mean people
disagree about politics and don't speak
for the rest of their lives they
disagree about a piece of furniture and
don't speak for the rest of their lives
and this is
um it's just so low shelf it's so it's
it's not a very high shelf way of living
but it would be sad for the relationship
to end permanently over covid and mask
restriction but this is not up to her
right except to her daughter right she
didn't end it her daughter did that's
true but just having the heart of
forgiveness I'm just sitting there open
that's fine if it comes back open be
open-handed yeah if they come back but
you know you cannot make people like you
you cannot make people behave you cannot
make people be nice
um you can't make people grow a brain
that don't have one
um you can't you just can't you just
have to accept them where they are and
just go that's forgiveness I'm just
going to let you be what you is and then
if you ever want to be something
different we'll talk about that too
that's okay but yeah this is
the the
this is a dangling thing in your
psychology it's hanging back there you
think about it when you wake up in the
morning and changing the will puts more
closure on this and allows you to move
on past this this loss that's very real
and uh Hang on we're gonna send you a
copy of Dr delony's book on your past
change your future
um I cannot think about
hardly anything that would be more
hurtful and harmful to have to go
through than that and it is
in many ways worse than a death
sorry I'm so sorry you're facing this